I'm here with Kristine Payne who created
muse that a neural network that
roat's the music that this flame in the
background over here where sting was one
of the coolest new network projects in
recent memory christina is amazing
journey she initially studied physics
and then attended julia which study
music and then took the people into a
deep learning specialization and wound
up working full-time at open AI where
she created Muse dance so how did you
first get interested in machine learning
it's sort of funny I as I would do
different piano concerts I always had a
trouble of needing to find someone to
come turn my pages which means in
chamber music and I figured maybe a
better way to do it would be to find a
computer program that could do it and I
played around with trying to get an eye
tracker that would would figure out
where I was looking on the page and turn
pages automatically and I learned that
you know probably to do this really well
I would have to learn about this thing
called machine learning which I knew
nothing about at that point and now
you're working at open the eye tell me
about your work there so actually I've
been really excited to be able to tie
together both my musical interests and
my interest now in AI I've been working
on a project called muse net which tries
to take all these recent advances that
we've had in natural language work and
apply them instead to music so I went
through the process of trying to turn a
regular sheet music into tokens that I
could then feed into a model and it's
been great fun it means I get to debug
by like listening to music trying to be
Brahms and a copepod of music was the
only transforming network where that's
going on that open the eye yeah can you
explain to listeners what is that about
yeah so transformer architecture is very
powerful architecture based on self
attention so the the model can learn how
far in the past it might need to look in
order to find the relevant information
so it makes it much easier to when
you're dealing with a long sequence you
can equally well look at the beginning
of the sequence which you might need in
music when
might need to return to a theme that you
haven't heard for a couple minutes yeah
so give it a piece of music you can look
way back at the last time this chorus
was played and then do the right thing
when synthesizing the new piece of music
exactly
you're also policy open the eyes
Scholars Program how was that yeah that
was an amazing opportunity for me it's a
program that opening eye has that is
specifically looking for people from
more unusual backgrounds and it was
really great to be paired with a mentor
who helped me kind of weave through and
it's such a big feel than to have
someone help you navigate you know which
research to pay attention to which
problems to do um I think it's so great
that you took the deep learning
specialization and that was part of your
journey
um for others wanting to volunteer for
stairs above a similar career would you
have any advice for them sure yeah I
mean I do feel that the deep learning
sequence was a huge part of the way I
started into this I remember actually as
the courses were coming out and we would
wait for each new course to come out and
I I realized like at that point I could
look anywhere like probably the material
is online but it was only as your videos
came out and you explain things in such
a good clear way that then I felt like I
had this intuition and I kind of
understood what was going on and then
actually the other thing that happened
is you guys invited me to stay on as a
mentor in the forums and that for me was
huge because it meant that rather than
just watching the videos I actually had
to think through and be able to explain
these things to other people kind of
think about problems that I you know
side cases that hadn't thought about as
carefully and then after that I went on
I did also the FAFSA AI sequence which I
loved a lot it's a that was a little bit
more diving into the code and and
working on specific problems the main
thing I'd say is like I am a big fan of
just finding a toy problem that you're
excited about finds some way that
machine learning relates to a field that
you know well and then it makes it
easier it's more it's more fun to work
on and it also means that you know maybe
you'll find some you'll have expertise
that nobody else has in this area
actually thank you for having served as
mentor
helping to pass on to others as well I
think it's a great point for a lot of
people is better to pick a COO even
smaller project then to sit around and
wait for the grand opening on before
starting to dive in so yeah Thank You
Christine I think you'll be an
inspiration to many others wishing to
break the AI and build a career and do
exciting work thank you thanks so much
it's really an honor to be here
[Music]